hi and welcome I am in the directors
branch but for my sins I'm also a
screenwriter very happy to be part of
this evening in which the Academy
celebrates the arrival of new
screenwriting voices I was going to
speak off the cuff but then I thought
only a fool would do that in a big room
full of good writers so a little crib
sheet you know I think all of us have
from growing up rules advice you know
proclamations things as were repeated to
us and thrown at us by our parents over
and over and over again Dhoni with your
mouth open look a person in the eye when
you shake their hands wear clean
underwear to a date you know that kind
of thing
in my house the line was from my father
there is nothing better than something
well written there is nothing better
than something well written there is
nothing better than something weirdness
nothing is alright Wow
now that was years of that screenwriting
of course is its own kind of writing as
B deviling in grueling and humiliating
as well as exhilarating as writing
poetry is to poets and writing novels is
to novelists but screenwriting is not
particularly about language you know
good dialogue of course is delightful
and will quote movie words forever but
it's never the main event screenwriter
screenwriting is not about detailed
description primarily there and most
certainly not about explaining what
characters are thinking and feeling it's
about their circumstances and their
actions and therefore about their
destinies that's just a presumptuous way
to say the story what these Nicholl
fellowship Award winners have done is
precisely that they've told us good
stories as Tom Rickman pointed out
yesterday they've done it with the
freedom that is of course rare success
will pit them it will pit you against a
host of compromises Kent the girl just
fall in love with someone her own age
does the charismatic Roman general
really have to die can't he just retired
to Sardinia
one of the features of our industries
that it often pays you not to be an
artist it pays you to conform to conform
to leave your wicked dirty bad
subconscious at the door let's face it
if your thoughts were not wicked and
scary you would not be writers I very
much enjoyed your scripts and admired
them and I envied them and I also envied
of course that they are already written
but now with affection I want to invite
you I want to challenge you to stay
writers that doesn't mean you can't or
shouldn't take work where you can to
exercise your considerable skills in the
pursuit of money for buying a house or
raising children or buying emergency
items like Manolos or Laker tickets but
every now and then remember the spirit
in which these scripts were written some
of the best movies in history were
written like that alone in the night for
no money and with this thing a horrible
smelly winged creature sitting on your
shoulder whispering nobody cares a lot
of people care believe me a lot of the
best people care so I beg you stay
artists